medicines are essential to save lives
and treat people who suffer from
coronavirus our priority is to ensure
that Europeans have access to the
medicines they need during this public
health crisis since the start of the
outbreak we have monitored the situation
with the support of our European Agency
for medicine we have engaged with the
industry to anticipate any possible
disruption in the supply of these
critical products indeed we need larger
quantities of medicines to treat
coronavirus patients and hospitals and
this is why today we adopted guidelines
to ensure that Europeans have access to
affordable medicines during this crisis
we ask that national governments lift
any export ban on medicines such
restrictions can lead to shortages
elsewhere in the European Union and it
is equally important that they avoid
stockpiling because this prevents
medicines from being in the pharmacies
and the hospitals where they are needed
but we also need increased production of
medicines industry needs to reorganize
its supply chains and production lines
accordingly and we help the industry to
do that including by giving them some
flexibility in regulation or
facilitating state aid where possible
and national authorities should consider
limiting the sale on line of medicines
that are essential for treating
coronavirus patients and finally we need
to step up action against disinformation
it can push citizens to stockpile or use
the wrong medicines so we have to
counter it and provide transparent
information to the public about the
available supply of medicines we are
faced with a pandemic and we see it as
our duty even more than usual to help
ensure that Europeans have the medicines
they need